Los Angeles California
home of beautiful beaches and Hollywood
Blockbusters
but in 2007 a dark story emerges from
the depths
for Halloween shark attacks in just over
three months locals are on high alert
why have the sharks of California
suddenly flipped the script
the answer could affect beachgoers
around the world
Calandra is an avid Outdoorsman who
resides on the California coast
of living in Malibu of just a really
good strong sense of community here just
an hour drive west of the city of Los
Angeles Malibu sits upon the pristine
Pacific Coast
it's a playland for families
Paradise for Surfers and a front row
seat for marine Wildlife enthusiasts
home to gray whales and bottlenose
dolphins sea lions and seals this area
is also
a shark Super Highway
cruising these waters are the thresher
shark which smacks and stuns its victims
with its long lethal tail
the Striking horn shark that prefers the
Sandy seafloor and the blue shark named
for its uniquely colored skin
despite the presence of these Predators
shark encounters along this Coast are
rare
but that's not the case for much longer
seven
paddle boards both competitively and
recreationally paddle boarding offers a
complete different perspective of the
water you can see fairly deep you can
see with swimming underneath you paddle
boarding is a form of meditation but his
calm is about to be shattered
it was a annual paddle board race which
was referred to the Tommy's on race
started out normal race the group
separated fairly quickly there was
probably three or four of us out in
front about halfway through the event
something unexpected catches Vic's eye I
ended up looking back as I turned about
30 feet 40 feet behind me I saw a Finn
come up
there's probably about a foot and a half
out of the water and it's closing in on
Vic it came up within a very short
period of time to about 10 or 15 feet
behind me I could see the girth it
wasn't just the fin it was stretched out
a foot and a half on each side of the
fin
this had been the largest shark I'd ever
seen
nearly half a mile offshore There's No
Escape it came up within a foot or two
of me and that's when it it began I
tried to strike at it and scare it away
and it was probably not the best move it
started to get more agitated
change completely
I was praying at that point
paddling
I get bumps
shark can bump the back of the board
I went down halfway into the water
held onto my board
and rolled back onto the board
shouts to nearby Racers for help
I'm yelling shark to them
one of them veers towards me and he
yells to me it's on your tail
keep paddling
I was completely terrified at that point
the Good Samaritan is Joe Everett an
off-duty lifeguard I just kind of tried
to hit the shark with the tip of my
board
it worked shark went away
there was this Eerie silence
and then he came back
and I believe that's when the real fight
happened
big strikes the shark with his paddle
while Joe punches the Predator again and
again this happened for about five or
six minutes which seemed like eternity
and then ultimately the shark went away
again
and we did not see the shark at any
point after that
after 20 terrifying minutes big shark
encounter is finally over we got to
Shore and just sat down I was in shock
you go through an experience like that
there's a moment of silence I think for
everyone when I gathered my thoughts and
such my daughter had come up to me and I
I was just thankful that you know I had
that opportunity to get back to my
daughter
Vic emerges unscathed
but not unaffected I had various
nightmares of encounters with sharks
after that but I knew I needed to get
back into the water a few days after the
incident Vic returns to the ocean I felt
that experience was one in a lifetime
event I knew it was something that was
going to change my perspective on things
for a while
so you can just see them cruising
through this area there goes a leopard
shark
Dr Chris Lowe runs the shark Lab at
California State University Long Beach
there are about 22 species of sharks
found along California coasts ranging
from species that hang right out off the
beach into lagoons to ones that live in
the open ocean but the species that
people interact with the most were the
ones found closest to the beach so those
include orange sharks they include
leopard sharks
and of course the one that everybody
knows the great white
to identify the species behind Vic's
attack Dr Lowe turns to the paddle
boarders eyewitness account
I could see the girth it wasn't just the
fin it was stretched out a foot and a
half on each side of the fin
this had been the largest shark I'd ever
seen
based on his description of the shark it
sounds like it was potentially an adult
white shark
white sharks can get up to about 21.5
feet long they're the largest predatory
fish on earth
historically white sharks are
responsible for more attacks off the
coast of Southern California and in fact
more attacks around the world than any
other species of shark
investigators know what species carried
out the attack but they still don't know
why
Vic has his own Theory
I'm paddling
I get bumped
the shark can bump the back of the board
it was curious and I believe it just
bumped me because it was inquisitive
the history of Vic's favorite sport
seems to support this idea
in 2007 paddle boarding was fairly rare
at that particular point and you're
starting to see more individuals farther
out in the shoreline than you typically
would
is curiosity the reason the shark bumped
Vic's board
sharks are absolutely curious animals
when there's new items in the
environment they tend to investigate
that
Dr Dan Huber of the University of Tampa
explores the theory
when a white shark is cruising through
the water it's looking up at the surface
and what it sees is a silhouetted torso
with limbs sticking off of it which
looks just like a Seal's body as the
sunlight is coming down and creating
that silhouette
if you add to that the fact that the
paddle border is making splashes in the
surface of the water as they're working
their way through the water that's also
going to draw the shark's attention into
that spot
could a paddle board entice a shark into
taking a closer look or bite
is this the cause of the sudden increase
in shark attacks
over the next three months three more
shark attacks rocked this Southern
California coastline making four
incidents in total that's more than
occurred in the previous 25 years
this shocking turn of events makes
headlines
it was big news people are scared and
rightly so the LA coastline is on alert
and locals want answers for Encounters
in one year between sharks and people
off the coast of Los Angeles is alarming
we just don't see that very often
in search of Clues investigators
discover a similarity between the
attacks all four encounters occurred
near the shoreline
Dr Lowe and a team of student
researchers investigate the movements of
sharks in that particular area
there was a state of incidents in a
location all within a short period of
time where a bunch of individuals were
bitten by sharks
the number one thing we would want to
know is how many sharks are present in
that area how much time are they
spending in that area are these just
individuals that are transient passing
through understanding both the number
and distribution of sharks in this
region will help Dr glow determine if
humans are at greater risk of being
bitten we're gonna put a drone up and
try to find some clear water to put the
bro
we really need to understand what these
animals are doing so we spy basically on
these animals
so these are baited remote underwater
video systems brovs for short
we're going to drop the breath here and
let it sit for a couple hours and let
the cameras Roll come back and pick it
up see what we got
[Music]
it acts like a selfie station
so we're even using cool new machine
learning algorithms to build libraries
of individuals that we can track over
time
so we have all these receivers all these
individual white sharks are individuals
that we detected in a five-day period
the data reveals something alarming so
you can see there are periods when
they're working right along the edge of
the beach this is where people are and
then other times of the day they're
outside but they're basically just going
back and forth along these areas
not only are sharks patrolling the
inshore area in large numbers they're
doing so dangerously close to humans
there are 10 sharks in this Frame one
two three four five six seven
individuals right there there's some
Surfers eight
nine ten
that's probably an eight foot white
shark there's the wave break right there
why are sharks spending so much time
close to shore
a chilling detail from one of the
attacks provides a new lead
back in 2007 I was actually surfing a
couple times a week before work I would
surf with some of the guys that I worked
with
Andrew sanagra has an Abiding Love of
the ocean and of its inhabitants I've
had plenty of encounters with sharks
where I've been swimming with them
I've swam with them all over the world
but in 2007 an unplanned shark encounter
turns Andrew's life upside down I never
would have thought in a million years
that the day would have ended the way
that it did
I was meeting my friends at their condo
right up on the beach we were gonna surf
in the morning after surfing we were
gonna go over to the Venice Street Fair
there had been a heatwave earlier in the
month but when we came to the beach
everything seemed normal
it's a Dale a lot like today actually it
was a little bit cooler out
we had been in there for a while
catching a few waves and I noticed this
large Shadow come under my board from
the left
my boards roughly eight feet long and
the shark was about the same size as my
board
so I could see this was a large animal
that passed directly below me
we're like all right maybe it's time to
go in
I look down and I can see that the shark
is on the wave in between us
the wave behind me crashed and knocked
my feet out from underneath me so I kind
of got kicked back
and that's where we made contact
a shark sinks its teeth into Andrew's
foot
it felt like I got hit with a large
rubber mallet
like someone took a mallet and swung it
as hard as it can it was just a hard
strike that just hit me all of a sudden
just as quickly as it hit
the shark is gone
I didn't know if there was going to be a
second attack
that's when I did become panicked and I
needed to get out of the water
when I looked down and saw my foot
at first there was nothing and then the
all of a sudden the blood started
pouring out at the top of my foot and
there was so much blood I still couldn't
tell how many puncture wounds there were
what was actually happening yet
a lifeguard bandages Andrew's wound and
the next day the surfer seeks medical
attention
the doctor on call at the time heard
that there was a shark bite and so he
came down and he in fact confirmed that
it looked like a classic bite wound the
chart tooth cut through the muscle in my
foot Andrew was on crutches for three
weeks but it takes nearly a year for him
to return to the water I definitely feel
lucky that the only thing that happened
to my foot was the puncture wounds it
could have been a lot worse
Andrew's incident occurs just two months
after VIXX part of an unnerving string
of four shark attacks off the coast of
Los Angeles
it's an uptick that forces local
authorities to act
there's been an increase in the number
of shark sightings which ultimately
makes it so the lifeguards will have to
shut an area of the beach down and
increase the number of Patrols
what's causing this disturbing surge
a clue from Andrew's attack could help
solve the mystery
Dr Huber investigates
now an important detail here is that
according to Andrew's account and also
from the doctors who attended to him was
that this wound was as deep as it is
wide across the surface which means that
a pretty large tooth would have sunk
into it to cause a lot of damage
it basically appeared like Andrew had
been stabbed in the foot and according
to Dr Huber there's only one shark
capable of inflicting such a wound it
appears that a white shark was
responsible for the attack
a white shark the same culprit
identified in Vic's encounter
but something makes this white shark
different
my boards roughly eight feet long and
the shark was about the same size as my
board
given that Andrew described the shark
that attacked him as being about the
size of his surfboard roughly in the 8
to 10 foot range this would mean that
Andrew was attacked by a juvenile white
shark juvenile white sharks tend to
spend time a bit closer to the coast
than do adult white sharks the reason
for this goes back to an amazing element
of great white physiology
white sharks have this really cool
characteristic called a counter current
heat exchanger it's an arrangement of
blood vessels inside their body that
helps them to retain body heat so that
they can Elevate their body temperature
compared to the surrounding water turns
out that adult white sharks are better
at doing this than juvenile white sharks
so juvenile white sharks tend to spend
more time in shallower warmer more
Coastal Waters could the temperature of
the water play a part in the attacks off
the Los Angeles Coast in 2007.
I've been living in Malibu for close to
35 years and you would go for years and
not hear about these particular
encounters with humans and great whites
what I've noticed now is that they seem
to come in waves more in the summer
months Dr Andrew lysing of the National
Oceanic Atmospheric Administration
specializes in tracking sea surface
temperatures he dives into the data from
the time of the spike and so you'll
notice during 2007 right around May is
when this whole region starts to warm up
and stays warm for most of the summer on
into the fall and this these
temperatures are up above six degrees
warmer than normal for this region the
whole thing would be classified as a
marine heat wave
the Marine heat wave of 2007 saw sea
water more than six degrees above normal
and it occurred in the exact same months
as the attacks
so the fact that there was warmer than
normal water temperatures in 2007 could
be a contributing factor to the spike in
attacks in Los Angeles
begin to come into Focus
investigators turned their attention to
a different freak occurrence on these
Shores one that poisoned a shark's prey
and just might explain the attacks
we rescue about three to five hundred
seals on sea lions a year Peter
wallerstein has spent 35 years working
as a first responder to distressed
animals
and in 2007 he Witnesses something
unusual five sea lions a day were
getting bitten a popular prey item of
white sharks sea lions are often seen
along Southern California Shores
including on the very day when Vic was
attacked
at the beginning of the race starts at
Zuma Beach and the race terminates at
the Malibu Pier there's a lot of
different marine mammals out in the
water sealed sea lion in 2007 sea lions
begin washing up on the beaches
in 2007 we saw domoic acid break out
which is really a horrible toxin it
affects your brain and does a lot of
damage
the milk acid is a neurotoxin produced
by a form of allergy that's somewhat
common off of the southern California
coast
it's one of the most devastating things
that happened in marine life in L.A
County pelicans get it and whales get it
and sea lions get it real bad too
could high levels of domoic acid play a
part in the spike
there's a variety of factors that can
lead to increases in demoic acid
concentration including elevated water
temperature and nutrient pollution
things like fertilizers running off from
the coast into those Waters that
combination of things basically feeds an
algal bloom and those algal blooms
result in increased concentrations of
domoic acid in the water
as smaller fish eat the algae and larger
animals eat the smaller fish the domoic
acid levels that are passed on increase
exponentially
this can lead to devastating
consequences for marine life toward the
top of the food chain like seals and sea
lions now the reason for this is because
domoic acid causes a spike in the
activity of the central nervous system
neurons in the brain start firing much
much more rapidly and all of that excess
activity can cause things ranging from
seizures to memory loss
sea Lion's tragedy may be a great whites
opportunity
hey guys Dr Lauren Palmer of The Marine
Mammal Care Center explores the
connection rescuing marine animals does
tell us something about the sharks
that they're preying on what size and
what time of year when how many so we
learn a lot about sharks by looking at
the prey that they go after
and what Dr Palmer has learned from her
work with poison pinnipeds is crucial to
the investigation domoic acid almost
certainly makes seals and sea lions more
vulnerable to shark attacks the sea
lions can be very lethargic they can
actually have seizures repeatedly they
can fall into a coma they can die
outright
normally pinnipeds are hunted almost
exclusively by adult great whites that's
because juveniles like the one that bit
Andrew lacked the size and strength to
take down these marine mammals
but that may not be the case if a
pinniped has been poisoned it's possible
that in 2007 there were a lot more
juvenile white sharks preying on sick
sea lions that they could actually
capture
but does demolic acid affect the shark's
nervous system the same way it doesn't
matter
we don't know
could vulnerable prey have lured
juvenile white sharks close to shore
putting them in direct contact with the
victims of the 2007 Spike
Dr Palmer examines the data
actually we don't see a correlation
between shark attacks and demoic acid
events thus far that could be because
the animals don't make it to shore
domoic acid is not the cause of the
spike
but one thing this Theory does show is
that a white shark's movements are
impacted by those of their prey
perhaps a different food source is
Central to understanding the spike
another attack holds a clue
Venice Beach has always been kind of the
mecca for surf and skate
I began surfing when I was a kid
surfed pretty much every other day with
my buddies one of Sam bendel's favorite
surf spots is near the Venice Pier I
always knew that there were sharks in
the water up and down the Pacific coast
I didn't really ever think twice about
them being here in Venice Beach
Sam Hits the water
gone down pure lights have gone up the
Moon is starting to rise a little bit so
there was still enough to see we'd been
out for about an hour and was paddling
out to get up over the crest of a wave
my left hand had gone into the water and
all the way to the back of my stroke
and something hit me
and I pulled my hand up you can see that
it was bleeding and I was like oh no
sharks
I started like paddling frantically in
with just Moonlight to guide him Sam
scrambles to shore I looked in my hand I
was like oh that's a lot of blood
it was just three cash scratch marks
that had a lot of blood going off of it
just like put a little bit of pressure
on or like all right uh no more night
surfing
Sam escaped Serious injury my hand
wasn't mangled I was thankful that it
wasn't any worse than it was but the
encounter leaves a lasting impression
have I ever gone night surfing again the
answer to that is a strong nope
not trying to relive the memories of
what I experienced but it won't stop me
from continuing to surf
bitten off the coast of Los Angeles in
just over three months
the surfer is unable to identify the
species of his attacker
so could this latest encounter also be
the work of the mighty great white
Dr Lowe examines the evidence so looking
at the photos it's really difficult to
tell especially from wounds that have
healed but small white sharks based on
the size of the wounds that's a
possibility
four attacks likely all by great whites
but what has changed to make the white
sharks near Los Angeles turn on people
another clue from Sam's encounter could
shed some light
[Music]
the Moon is starting to rise a little
bit so there was still enough to see
the Moon
the phases of this ethereal orb serve an
important role in nature
the lunar cycle can have a large effect
on marine life there are lots of cases
around the world of different marine
organisms reproducing synchronized to
full moons
Dr Huber knows one such creature whose
reproduction corresponds with the lunar
cycle
it's Slender silver and found along the
coast of Southern California
running or small Bait fish that live
along the coast and on full moons during
the summer they Beach themselves to
spawn and then they get washed out by
waves now what that means is that during
full moons along the southern California
coast sometimes there are large
collections of bait fish right up
against the coast and anytime there's a
large collection of bait fish that could
potentially bring in Predators an influx
of small fish like Grunion can lure in
medium fish
in turn these medium fish attract even
larger animals like sharks
and that puts these Predators right in
the path of surfers like Sam Bendel
so the question some people have posited
is that white sharks are attracted to
Grunion spawn why not there are
thousands of fish at these spots
that's a possibility but the fact that
we've never found a Grunion in a white
shark's stomach probably suggests that
there's no correlation between Grunion
spawning and the probability of sharks
biting people at those locations
while great whites do Feast on Bait fish
it seems Grunion are not on their menu
this cyclical spawning does not explain
the surge in shark attacks
perhaps the presence of fish is
important in another way
a detail from Sam's attack site
could turn the investigation on its head
I started hattling frantically in ran up
to the top of the pier and then looked
down and we could see two or three big
silhouettes
we kind of all collectively in that
moment realized that there was wildlife
in the ocean waiting to get their
evening meal
Sam was surfing near the Venice Pier at
the time of his attack
the Venice Pier is a popular fishing
location where Anglers reel in mackerel
Pacific Bonito
Queen fish and sometimes larger sea life
I got a call about a harbor seal that
was caught and so we went to the pier or
see a guy reeling up as real and at the
end of it is a harbor seal with a hook
in his mouth it's a scenario that seems
to be occurring more frequently there's
been an increase in fishing from Piers
off of the Los Angeles coast and this is
potentially problematic because large
animals can be hooked and brought closer
to shore where people are using the
beach so this would have put a lot of
blood into the water which could have
drawn in other Predators so potentially
pier fishing is a way to increase the
number of interactions between people
and sharks
according to Dr Lowe it's not just
hooked pinnipeds that might pique a
shark's interest and cause an attack
fishing piers may be problematic in
another way one of our focuses is really
on the behavior of sharks in the ecology
why do they do what they do and of
course that's hard to do without looking
at how they interact with people because
we've become part of the ocean ecology
so fishing has been going on off
California beaches and Piers for over
100 years in fact many of our ocean
piers were built for that purpose
but white sharks really weren't around
and not create a number 100 years ago
it's been their conservation recovery
that has brought them back
and now we have people fishing with new
kinds of gear these guys are using heavy
tackle big steel leader big hooks
they're specifically targeting these
sharks
sharks are no different than all other
animals when that animal gets scared or
gets in a fight it gets an adrenaline
rush a push
so a shark that's caught on a hook and
line for example it feels it's being
attacked and anything near it it may
attribute to its being attacked
and this is kind of dangerous because
there are people swimming and surfing in
these places
so now you have an angry shark that is
fighting for its life to get off that
line and that shark is lashing out back
and forth thinking that maybe this guy
is the thing that's trying to harm you
the presence of fishing piers be at the
root of the Southern California Spike
perhaps the answer to the 2007 attacks
may be found in analyzing another eerily
similar shock encounter that occurred
nearby in 2014. this is crazy to say
this but I've been swimming consistently
for 50 years
Eve Robles has a deep passion for long
distance swimming but in 2014 a routine
swim near a fishing pier ends in
disaster and almost ends his life
it was a bright sunny day that morning
weather was warm the water temperature
was warmer than normal my group of
swimmers and I we got up and started a
two-mile swim starting from Hermosa pure
to Manhattan Pier
unbeknownst to Steve and his friends
fishermen on the Manhattan Beach Pier
have a large fish on the line
a shark
we're about 100 yards from finishing the
swim
that's when I saw the shark underneath
me
the shark breaks free of the fisherman's
hook I saw it to be about an eight foot
shark and it surfaced right up in front
of me
his head was out of the water and we're
staring at each other eye to eye
and I said oh my God this thing's too
close
this could be it this is my last moment
and then it came in and bit me
the shark locked in on my torso
they had to fight
my hands went up I grabbed its nose and
I just kept pushing and pushing
and once the shark released me
I was able to swim a couple Strokes away
from it on my back and right behind me
about five Strokes behind was my other
swimmer friend
I jump on top of them in a panic saying
I got bit I got bit and then he looks
over and he sees just all kinds of blood
coming out of me
I didn't know the extent of the damage
I was really afraid that I might bleed
out
a group of guys were carrying me up to
the sand I was just screaming and
screaming as loud as I ever have
[Music]
I'm scared I might die
doctors use stitches to repair the
slashes on Steve's right side the shark
itself
get me right on my torso it started
right on my my chest here one bite
grabbed all the way to the back
and it held on for five seconds
and
I mean
no harrowing Steve's attack may also be
revealing could a discovery from his
incident be the key to unlocking LA's
2007 Spike once and for all
so we see from Steve's attack clear
evidence of the lower jaw and the upper
jaw of the white shark
Dr Huber's bite analysis concludes that
a great white is responsible for both
the 2007 attacks and this 2014 encounter
if the incidents share a common culprit
could they also share a common cause
in the case of Steve's attack both Steve
and the shark were victims that shark
had been hooked and was fighting for its
life for 40 minutes it was simply just
trying to get away
Steve on the other hand just had a case
of bad luck he was swimming through the
water that that same shark was trying to
escape from
Steve got attacked and the shark was
surely stressed out and so they both
lost in that situation
is proximity to fishing piers the same
reason for the 2007 Spike near Los
Angeles
fishing from a pier can potentially
bring large dangerous animals into
proximity with beachgoers who are simply
trying to enjoy the water but the fact
of the matter is that during the spike
in Los Angeles in 2007 only one of the
four attacks involved fishing which
means that this type of fishing is not
the Smoking Gun it's not the main factor
in contributing to these attacks
as investigators consider New Leads
Surfer Sam Bendel proposes his own
hypothesis I don't blame the shark
biting me I think he may have mistaken
me for a seal or another piece of
wildlife that was prey to him
[Music]
[Applause]
same idea investigators considered
earlier in the wake of Vic Calandra's
attack the majority of white shark
attacks occur on Surfers and the reason
for that is because the silhouette of a
surfboard and the surfer's body coming
off of that board looked just like the
preferred prey type of white sharks
which are things like seals and sea
lions
three of the four victims in 2007 were
on surfboards or paddle boards when
attacked could mistaken identity be the
cause of the LA Spike
[Music]
local drone photographer Carlos gowna
has striking Visual Evidence that could
answer this question I lived in Malibu
in 2007 I was well aware of the amount
of shark encounters because a lot of my
friends are Surfers and so I remember
quite vividly people come in and telling
me look I was surfing today I saw a
breach we've got a paddle boarder going
straight at a shark the shark is going
straight at the paddle border both of
them meet the only one to react
is actually the shark
in this footage the shark swims away
from the paddleboard rather than
investigating it as prey contradicting
the idea of mistaken identity
and according to Dr Lowe this is the
behavior he'd expect to see
struggle with this Theory and the reason
is is these animals take down some of
the most Nimble highly social adapted
animals for swimming in the ocean marine
mammals to say that they can't tell the
difference between a silhouette of a
board that makes a different sound
exhibits no similar odor
just doesn't seem right to me sharks
mistaking Surfers and paddle boarders
for pinnipeds is not behind the 2007
Spike
perhaps there's another aspect of the
marine mammals Behavior to explore sea
lions breed during the summer months on
islands off the coast of Southern
California so in those summer months and
into the fall there's an elevated number
of potential prey items for white sharks
marine mammals have been a conservation
success story in the United States over
the course of the last 40 years as it
turns out despite in the tax off of Los
Angeles in 2007 coincided with the
reproductive time of the seals and sea
lions that live there so while seal and
sea lion populations in general are
increasing they happen to be
particularly High during the summer to
early fall months off the coast of
Southern California and this is exactly
when the spike in attacks occur
could an increase in sea lions have
drawn white sharks closer to shore
Dr Lowe believes the answer to this
question lies in analyzing a great
whites diet
to do so his research team examines a
surprising aspect of the Predator's
Anatomy its skin this is our biopsy
punch and we use this to take tissue
samples from sharks and to do a stable
eye stops analysis did you get tissue
yeah
we did tissue samples because you know
the old saying you are what you eat
that's one way we can try to figure out
what white tricks you're eating without
having to cut them open and see what's
in their stomachs so with the tissue
sample I dry it and I crush it in the
lab make it powder so you can go through
a machine to get that stable isotope
signature
alrighty I'm gonna scoop it now then
looking at two stable eye step
signatures carbon and nitrogen and what
these signatures tell you might be of
like what type of food discharge is
eating what they discover could upend
certain beliefs about a white shark's
diet and may also solve the 2007 Spike
so we know that white sharks will
definitely feed on sea lions it's not a
fave northern elephant seal the fave
harbor seals pretty good
California sealant we'll eat them if we
have to
this preference between pinnipeds may be
integral to the investigation as
research from Dr Lowe's team suggests
that although there are more sea lions
in the water sharks are surprisingly not
eating more of them
it's not that there's more sea lions
there's also more elephant seals and if
white sharks prefer to eat those why
wouldn't they a pinniped population boom
is not to blame
as investigators go back to the drawing
board a shared detail between all of the
attacks emerges
there had been a heatwave earlier in the
month I believe encounters with humans
and great whites I think it comes in
certain ways it seems to be more in the
summer months
the investigation already revealed that
LA's 2007 shark attacks occurred between
June and early October coinciding with a
marine heat wave
but what about Steve roblay's attack in
2014 2014 was an unusual year the water
was warmer than normal
we were seeing unusually high water
temperatures
Dr Andrew lysing checks to see if the
data supports Steve's observation
so in the beginning of July 2014 we had
this set up where we had extremely warm
Waters throughout the bite and more to
the South and these are still warm
they're off my chart here there's
something like seven or eight degrees
above normal a massive Marine Heat Wave
here Dr leising confirms water
temperatures are unusually high around
the la coast in both 2007 and 2014. the
reason is because of the wind patterns
in the region the winds are actually
going off this direction instead of
along the coast and they're much weaker
than normal so you're not going to get
much Coastal upwelling and mixing of
those surface waters so it's not going
to cool down instead it can just kind of
keep on heating up right in the surface
there's other result of a complex
weather event called an El Nino El ninos
are warmer La Nina's are cooler they're
normal and then there's 2014.
bring it was one of the strongest El
ninos we've had and it collided with The
Blob in the Pacific Northwest The Blob
is an unusual mass of warm water that
was first detected in late 2013.
oceanographers have not seen that even
in climate records going back 10 000
years
but how does this warmer water affect
sharks what I'm seeing from 2007 was
there was this fairly warm pool of water
that got closer and closer to the shore
than the animals also are sort of
smudged down into a smaller region so
basically you would have the same number
of animals but crunched into a smaller
area our wind drop down and we have
warmer water along the beaches which
many of the juvenile white sharks are
seeking out that means we are putting
lots of people that recreate in our
Coastal ocean in close proximity to
sharks proximity Is Everything
a viable theory for the 2007 Spike
emerges
higher than normal water temperatures
bring sharks closer to shore leading to
increased interactions with humans
whenever we see a spike in shark attacks
we tend to try to look for a single
Smoking Gun but the fact of the matter
is that nature Works in complex systems
and there often isn't a single causative
Factor what we know is that there was
elevated water temperatures so now we've
got more prey in the water which could
be drawing white sharks closer to the
shore to hunt on these animals and
potentially leading to an increase in
the number of attacks and this whole
situation likely brought white sharks
into proximity with beachgoers off of
Los Angeles in 2007.
with the mystery solved La residents and
the survivors of the 2007 attacks can
breathe the sigh of relief I actually
grew a deep respect for great white
sharks if I was paddle boarding again
and ran into this situation again I
think I would have a completely
different reaction I don't believe I'd
strike at it I think my reaction caused
the shark to pursue me more so I think
on a go forward basis I'd be more of
observation mode and leave it at that
see where it rolls
shocking warming Trends around the la
coast are also happening worldwide which
means shark and human encounters could
continue to rise I think people are
scared of sharks mostly because they're
not around them very often and when they
do have encounters people think of the
worst type of encounter I think sharks
can be aggressive but I think that is
few and far between and those are the
only incidents that people remember
I wouldn't let anybody tell you oh
surfing's dangerous you're going to get
eaten by a shark don't don't fall for
that it's it's amazing the rewards far
outweigh the little nips
[Music]